un sprint de promotion des entrevues à
répétition déjà venu au festival de
cannes en tant qu'actrice aux côtés de
xavier dolan c'est en tant que cinéaste
que monia chokri et y revient une
nouvelle casquette et beaucoup de
responsabilités en plus et je pense que
déjà d'être dans un premier film où
certains verts sont tellement une belle
validation de la part du festival que
j'y vais avec joie puis j'essaie
vraiment de moi je les assume ce film
l'un après évidemment qui veut qu'il ya
des gens qui meurent pas mais qu'est-ce
que je peux faire c'est pas grave
à ses côtés anne élisabeth bossé qui
tient le rôle titre dans le film no
revient toujours pas d'être à cannes je
prends plein photos de la scène de juste
représente
nous observons peut-être pas dans la vie
donc je j'essaie d'en profiter
le film la femme de mon frère est
présenté en ouverture la section un
certain regard du festival
ce qui vaut à son équipe de gravir les
marches sur le mythique tapis rouge un
moment à la fois solennel et émouvant
qui se vit avec des papillons d'un vent
dans la salle les amis nos proches sont
venus en nombre soutenir la nouvelle
réalisatrice des amis comme xavier dolan
monia chokri lors des dix ont fini j'ai
une vive émotion à être ici ce soir
devant vous parce que j étais ya neuf
ans donc je suis né il ya neuf ans comme
actrice sous vos yeux et peut-être jeune
et très comme cinéaste
ce soir je perds mais quelque chose de
plus moi pour la deuxième partie c'est
quoi l'histoire comme xavier dolan monia
chokri s'intéresse aux relations
familiales
le film qu'elle avait écrit et réalisé
raconte l'histoire d'un frère et d'une
soeur sofia et karine une relation
fusionnelle qui se tend lorsqu'entre
dans le portrait la nouvelle copine du
frère jean sont une histoire très
personnelle pour monia chokri alors
lorsque les lumières s'allument dans la
salle et que les applaudissements se
prolonge
l'émotion est vive la pression et le
stress retombe
outre les prix décernés dans la
sélection un certain regard le film son
premier long métrage est aussi en lice
pour la caméra d'or mais au delà de la
réaction du jury et des critiques
il ya aussi l'opinion des cinéphiles qui
pourront se faire un avis par eux mêmes
très bientôt puisque la femme de mon
frère sera présenté au québec à partir
du 6 juin et en france à partir du 26
mai si jean françois bélanger radio
canada card